[Music]
well twitching gears now to Katie Holmes
she turned New York into her own
concrete catwalk and wonder what has
inspired this new cool and confident
Katie you can see it in that stretch and
inner smile a source close to Katie says
her newfound confidence as a result of
Fox cats yes we called it that newly
public romance and that the two were in
constant contact as Katie took on the
Big Apple yesterday sending voice memos
instead of text quote she was talking
about him all day and gushing about how
much fun she has with him he's got that
glow and she's doing that self-assured
hands on her hips thing showing off her
super toned figure in this that pose and
floral halter dress for attending New
York Fashion Week
Katie's own fashion was on point with
count'em three more looks the same day
getting some afternoon shopping done in
a floral sweater and distressed jeans
and later attending the premiere of PAL
Posen documentary house of Aziz Katie
capped off her day at the US Open in a
comfy denim jumper and tweed blazer
looking like she was having a blast we
love seeing the usually low-key Katy up
in the fun factor our source says she's
become more of a homebody after her
divorce but now that her relationship
with Jamie is no longer a secret quote
she's letting down her guard and be more
open
you